handmade Pikachu rare so this is just
super unique like somebody just falls in
love with it with a good photo and now
you sell it for 30 bucks and if you're a
Pikachu fan and you bought everything
already on Earth this is not something
you own One of a Kind look at this
Beauty look at this gorgeous handmade
Pikachu she wanted two dollars she
didn't get it she got a dollar uh-huh
handmade Jersey for one of a kind uh-huh
I'll take bids right now if you want it
for 30 but I won't take it because
that's underpriced this might be 45. oh
it's not a Pikachu it is a Pikachu
what's everyone saying cool fight Evie I
guess that makes it 25 bucks handmade
Eevee right now I know what Pikachu
looks like it's a fat little CB I got a
TV I'm sorry I apologize I'm 47
I missed the was too old when
they hit hard but I'm learning
and I appreciate you all thank you for
the help